.
SO IN CALIFORNIA, INSULIN COSTS
WILL BE CAPPED AND AFFORDABLE.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU, BECAUSE WE
NOW KNOW THAT DONALD TRUMP'S
LAWYERS ARE IN TALKS WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION INTO
JANUARY 6th.
AS YOU KNOW, THERE HAVE BEEN
OTHER DEVELOPMENTS REGARDING THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL, PAT
CIPOLLONE AND SO ON.
DO YOU THINK IT'S TIME FOR YOUR
COMMITTEE TO HAND OFF THIS
INVESTIGATION INTO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
HAS THE COMMITTEE OR ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE GIVEN ANY
CONSIDERATION OF THAT?
HAVE YOU HEARD THAT CONVERSATION
COME OUT SINCE THE DOJ HAS MADE
SOME PROGRESS OR APPEARS TO BE
MAKING PROGRESS?
MERRICK GARLAND SEEMS TO BE
MOVING FORWARD.
MAYBE IT IS TIME FOR THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE TO WIND DOWN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> WE HAVE DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES.
THEIR OBJECTIVE IS TO SEE IF
THERE'S EVIDENCE SUFFICIENT TO
INDICT PEOPLE AND PROSECUTE THEM
FOR A CRIME.
OUR MISSION IS TO FIND THE
TRUTH, TELL IT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, AND THEN MAKE
SUGGESTIONS FOR LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES THAT WOULD PREVENT THIS
KIND OF THING FROM EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN.
WE -- AS THE CHAIRMAN ANNOUNCED,
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE JUST A FEW
MORE HEARINGS, PROBABLY IN
SEPTEMBER WE ARE GOING TO ISSUE
A REPORT.
NEW INFORMATION IS COMING IN.
SO THE TWO EFFORTS ARE NOT IN
CONFLICT WITH EACH OTHER.
THEY'RE COMPLEMENTARY, I
BELIEVE.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU'RE LIGHTING
A FIRE UNDER THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT BY KEEPING THE
INVESTIGATION GOING?
>> IT'S HARD TO KNOW.
I MEAN, THEY DON'T REPORT IN TO
US, NOR SHOULD THEY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
PROSECUTORS GENERALLY DON'T GIVE
PRESS RELEASES, THEY DON'T
CONSULT WITH LEGISLATIVE BODIES.
IF THEY HAVE EVIDENCE, THEY LET
YOU KNOW BY INDICTING SOMEONE.
SO WE'LL FIND OUT, ALONG WITH
THE REST OF THE WORLD, IF THEY
ANY A CRIME IS COMMITTED AND
THERE'S EVIDENCE TO PROVE IT.
MEANWHILE, WE WILL FINISH OUR
WORK, AND I THINK THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WILL BE WELL SERVED BY
BOTH EFFORTS, I HOPE.
>> THERE ARE MORE QUESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ANSWERED ABOUT THE
MISSING SECRET SERVICE TEXTS.
I KNOW YOU COMMITLY WILL LOOK AT
THAT, FROM THE DAY OF THE
CAPITOL ATTACK.
THE AGENCY IS GIVING
INVESTIGATORS THE PERSONAL CELL
PHONE NUMBERS OF AGENTS.
THAT IS A VERY UNUSUAL STEP.
CAN YOU CONFIRM WHETHER THE
COMMITTEE WAS GIVEN SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION OR IS IN THE PROCESS
OF PERHAPS TAKING A LOOK AT THAT
INFORMATION?
>> WE DON'T PUBLICLY DISCUSS THE
EVIDENCE UNDER OUR RULES, AND WE
HAVEN'T VOTED TO RELEASE IT.
BUT WE ARE GOING TO FOLLOW THIS
TO THE END.
I'LL TELL YOU, THE SECRET
SERVICE WAS TOLD BY THE
COMMITTEES OF JURISDICTION
BEFORE THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
EXISTED TO PRESERVE ALL THE
EVIDENCE.
11 DAYS LATER THEY RELACED IT.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND OUT
ABOUT IT AND SAT ON THAT
INFORMATION, DIDN'T TELL THE
COMMITTEE FOR MORE THAN A YEAR.
AND THEN WHEN FORENSICS STARTED,
TOLD THE SECRET SERVICE TO STOP
THE FORENSICS, WHICH IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
AND THE OTHER THING OF CONCERN
IS THAT, YOU KNOW, WE WERE
WORKING WITH THE SECRET SERVICE.
THEY WERE SENDING OVER
INFORMATION.
IT WASN'T UNTIL WE ISSUED A
SUBPOENA THAT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF RECORDS STARTED
APPEARING.
SO I HAVE SOME CONCERNS.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD LOOK, JIM.
I WANT TO GIVE CREDIT TO THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY,
WHO HAS NAMED A PERSON OF
TREMENDOUS INTEGRITY AS AN
ADJUNCT GENERAL COUNSEL TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS DONE RIGHT.
IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
COINCIDENCES.
>> WHY NOT HAUL THE DIRECTOR OF
THE SECRET SERVICE IN FRONT OF
YOUR COMMITTEE?
>> WE'RE NOT RULING ANYTHING
OUT.
BUT WE ARE INTENDING TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS, AND JUST TO
GET THE TRUTH.
IT'S A CONCERN, AS WELL AS --
>> WOULD THAT BE A REASONABLE
REQUEST TO MAKE, TO TALK TO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SECRET SERVICE?
>> WE DON'T OBJECT TO THAT, BUT
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO DIG IN
AND GET ALL OF THE DOCUMENTS,
WHETHER OR NOT HE KNEW ABOUT
THAT, WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT WE ARE -- LET ME JUST SAY
THIS, WITHOUT ANNOUNCING OUR
WITNESS LIST, WE'RE GOING TO
TALK TO EVERYBODY WHO CAN LET US
KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND THESE TEXTS ARE JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF MISSING TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE RECORDS.
TO REMIND VIEWERS, WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MISSING TEXTS FROM TOP
OFFICIALS, TORN UP DOCUMENTS,
GAPS IN CALL LOGS, AND SO ON.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
>> AND MARK MEADOWS BURNING
DOCUMENTS IN HIS FIREPLACE.
DON'T FORGET THAT.
>> LET'S NOT FORGET THAT ONE
EITHER.
SO THIS WAS A CONCERTED EFFORT
INSIDE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
TO MAKE SURE THERE WAS NO PAPER
TRAIL, WAS IT NOT?
>> IT DOESN'T LOOK GOOD, DOES
IT?
AND THE COVERUP ALWAYS GETS YOU,
NOT ALWAYS JUST THE MISCONDUCT.
>> DO YOU THINK WE'LL EVER GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THAT?
>> IT'S OUR INTENT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
EVERY TIME A TEXT IS SENT,
THERE'S THE SENDER AND THE
PERSON WHO RECEIVES THE TEXT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO TRACK THIS
DOWN, USE FORENSICS, WE'RE GOING
TO BE GOING TO THE TELECOMS TO
SEE IF THEY CAN RECOVER THIS
MATERIAL AND THE LIKE.
BY THE WAY, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS IN IT, BUT WE FULLY EXPECT TO
GET OR HOPE TO GET THE -- ALL
THE NEXT MESSAGES SENT BY MR.
JONES, WHO JUST LOST HIS
DEFAMATION CASE.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO FIND
OUT, GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS
AND LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT WE FOUND OUT.
>> I WAS ABOUT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT, AN ATTORNEY FOR THE
FAMILIES OF SANDY HOOK FAMILIES
THAT THEY HAVE ASKED FOR ALEX
JONES' PHONE RECORDS, WHO YOU
JUST MENTIONED.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO LOOK FOR IN
THOSE RECORDS?
>> WELL, WE KNOW THAT HIS
BEHAVIOR DID INCENTIVIZE SOME OF
THE JANUARY 6th CONDUCT, AND WE
WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'LL FIND IN
THE TEXTS, BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THEM.
BUT WE'LL LOOK AT IT AND LEARN
MORE, I AM SURE.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE WIFE OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE CLARENCE
THOMAS, GINNI THOMAS, IS THAT NO
LONGER GOING TO BE AN AVENUE YOU
WOULD PURSUE?
THERE WAS THE PROSPECT SHE WOULD
BE INTERVIEWED AT ONE POINT.
WHAT IS THE LATEST ON THAT?
WAS WELL, WHEN WE INDICATED WE
WANTED TO HEAR FROM HER, SHE
MADE A PUBLIC STATEMENT THAT SHE
WAS EAGER TO COME IN.
SHE LOOKED FORWARD TO TALKING TO
THE COMMITTEE.
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT, IT'S BEEN
PUBLICLY REPORTED THAT SHE'S
RETAINED COUNSEL, AND SO THERE
IS DISCUSSION.
BUT SHE'S NEVER SAID PUBLICLY,
SO FAR AS I'M AFFAIR THROUGH HER
COUNSEL, THAT SHE HAS ANYTHING
OTHER THAN WHAT SHE STATED,
WHICH IS TO COME IN TO TALK TO
US.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY AT THIS
POINT.
>> I APPRECIATE YOU INDULGING ME
AS I JUMP AROUND, BUT I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO BRING UP
THE FACT THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP ADDRESSED
CPAC OVER THE WEEKEND.
AS YOU KNOW, THERE WAS THIS
INFORMAL CPAC STRAW POLL, NOT A
SCIENTIFIC POLL, BUT IT IS A
MEASURING STICK FOR PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES, AS YOU KNOW.
AND WHEN ASKED, YOU KNOW, WHO
THEY PREFERRED TO SEW AS THE
NOMINEE IN 2024, DONALD TRUMP
GOT 69% OF THE VOTE.
IN FEBRUARY, HE GOT 59% OF THE
VOTE.
THAT MEANS THE CONSERVATIVE
SUPPORT FOR TRUMP HAS GONE UP
SINCE THESE JANUARY 6th
HEARINGS.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING, HOW DO
YOU EXPLAIN THAT, AND, YOU KNOW,
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE PROSPECT
THAT YOU HAVE POTENTIALLY
SOMEBODY LIKE DONALD TRUMP, WHO
INCITED AN INSURRECTION, WHO HAS
NOT SHOWN ANY REMORSE FOR IT,
WHO CONTINUES TO LIE ABOUT THE
2020 ELECTION, POTENTIALLY
POSITIONING HIMSELF AS THE
NOMINEE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IN THE NEXT PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW ATTENDS
THAT CONVENTION.
I THINK THEY HAD, YOU KNOW, THE
PILLOW GUY THERE, AND SOME
EXTREME INDIVIDUALS.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT REFLECTS
NORMAL REPUBLICANS IN THE
COUNTRY, I'M IN NO POSITION TO
SAY.
I WILL SAY THIS, AS I TRAVEL
AROUND, REPUBLICANS REGULAR
REPUBLICAN VOTERS ARE COMING UP
TO ME IN GREAT NUMBERS, THANKING
ME FOR THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
WORK.
AND THEY ALWAYS SAY, I'M A
REGISTERED REPUBLICAN, AND I
VOTED FOR TRUMP, BUT THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
A VERY INTERESTING PHENOMENON.
>> FROM TIME TO TIME, WE HEAR
THAT, AS WELL.
A LOT OF FOLKS, IT SEEMS WHO ARE
AFRAID TO TAKE ON THE FORMER
PRESIDENT INSIDE THE REPUBLICAN
PA